cryptocurrencies are not an investment
their way of empowering people no
don'tdon't in my fancy Manette look I
know there's it that an opening up it
gives them a step what you don't know be
going yet
I've been a markets reporter for ten
years but I've never seen anything
nearly as wild as the cryptocurrency
frenzy Bitcoin has been a wild ride
trading now at 18,000 dropping also
nearly fifteen percent beyond Bitcoin it
seems like everybody wants to start
their own cryptocurrency kodak playboy
venezuela and many others could have
like millions of these different tokens
all around the world I've done research
interviewed experts Hey it's team I got
a few questions for you and read a lot
then I realized that if you really want
to understand this crypto craze you kind
of have to be part of it so why wouldn't
we at the Wall Street Journal create our
own cryptocurrency but this is very very
exciting and a very good way to explore
a little-known booming industries
seeking help from eccentric
professionals like this crypto miner in
Japan and so once I show you guys a
little dialog and asking many others for
advice we actually created the WSJ coin
[Music]
my name is Steve Russa Lilla and I cover
cryptocurrencies for The Wall Street
Journal so how do you exactly create a
cryptocurrency where do you start let's
first do what any sophisticated
resourceful reporter would do in my
situation Google it create your own
crypto asset today so these websites
allow anyone to create a cryptocurrency
in a few clicks they can even help you
take the next step
launching and selling your coins to
investors through something called an
initial coin offering or ico
that's basically an IPO but for crypto
currencies that seems too simple I need
to know what's behind all of this and
there's one place in the world that has
a great reputation for crypto currencies
Japan here I come
[Music]
for the past few years Japan a country
of robots video games and high
technology has been considered to be a
true crypto paradise
the secretive inventor of Bitcoin
Satoshi Nakamoto supposedly comes from
Japan and despite this markets numerous
setbacks mount Cox unexpectedly shut
down today the crypto industry here has
flourished in recent years in heart
thanks to supportive government
regulation it's such a big business that
someone even created a cryptocurrency
pop band just for marketing purposes
[Applause]
[Music]
receive our motto motto pizza law says I
had kept you could open up member things
or not member to stick a toaster my stay
Iraheta Suzanne yo Cara
Kimmy touch a cryptocurrency God is not
there you are a must a mosquito Kaname
the hippie so the secret I must a the
total then Canoga Rebecca very messed up
we are trying to create our own
cryptocurrency do you have any advice
for us oh my god I almost you know you
must go to get Betty stand up Billy
circa well I'm not sure I'm ready for
that just yet
[Applause]
before we create our own cryptocurrency
we need to understand why many people
think this can really change the world
and Japan offers us a glimpse of what a
true crypto society looks like I
traveled to a zoo
a small city north of Tokyo it's a
three-hour journey by bullet train here
people are already experimenting with
crypto currencies on the ground this is
Professor yeah sushi Fuji a blockchain
fanatic he drives what he calls a
blockchain car an electric vehicle whose
power is automatically paid using
Bitcoin these days when you get lunch at
the campuses cafeteria instead of using
cash you can now pay with Piarco the
University of Isis own cryptocurrency
so what are some of the benefits of this
cryptocurrency in only a minute to to
stay well Krish took our last a monkey
saya akan anonymous I thought hey kar
komak ah no kids I gotta do even in
Martino Cartier do an update
following the success of several pilot
projects he is now looking at expanding
by occas network to the local town no
O'Connell Nagaraju mean ricotta gnocchi
Targa economist ricotta it was so it at
ecology okano toasted coconut thickness
Fuji argues that this way if an economic
crisis erupts subsidies could be
distributed to those in need on the
basis of actual data in short that means
a society where money flows easily and
quickly but also a place where the local
government knows all about its citizens
habits but the small town of izu is not
the only one
aiming at using crypto this way Hennis
whele has launched a crypto to attract
investment and trade oil in spite of
international sanctions and heaps of
companies are finding good reasons to
create their own virtual currencies
shipping giant Maris is doing it for
trading goods Kodak is launching Kodak
coin for photographers playboy came up
with a vise token for porn users there
are even coins for businesses like
cannabis and dental care other kryptos
have ridiculous names but people have
invested some real money into things
called Trump coin dogecoin or garlic
coin I know it sounds dodgy according to
experts proving this industry is legit
is one of its biggest challenges I think
one of the biggest risk I've got facing
the crypto community globally right now
is actually the presence of bad apples
there was a lot of fraud there is fraud
and they will be fun so what can
rightfully be called a crypto currency
technically anything that relies on
blockchain technology it's basically an
open accounting system the reason why
it's so popular is that every
transaction is recorded by a bunch of
computers in different parts of the
world in theory the system is fast and
makes fraud and hacks particularly hard
because the same information is stored
in so many places and famously it allows
you to bypass traditional third parties
like banks or central banks for
companies there are a couple more
benefits like in that Japanese
university blockchain makes it easy to
amass a lot of user data and even more
importantly companies can use it to
raise cash for example file coin a data
storage company raised 257 million
dollars by selling their own coins to
investors that's what's called an ICO
for initial point offering but of course
for all this to work you need a lot of
power a lot of compute
power
[Music]
the blockchain relies on people like
Asuka Mashiro in the industry people
call him a miner
I know oh yeah mom Musti yeah Mero
Tiffany you musta tada
it must not oh mama you karate for today
uh no just a shoot you
I know mr. Tucker oh ah so Rebecca
didn't not about my jaw
I know chichi God God I had a nice idea
but today I know Kiko oh and mother
nothing much I meet the 21 year old in
an old industrial building on the
outskirts of Tokyo
he recently quit college to expand his
mining facility so this nano total
dioxide the doors a headquarter business
not a kid I know their team are
appointed attorney nunavut a kooky
Okinawan it's Tomas so how does he turn
all this electric power and servers into
money when coins change hands miners
compete to record the transactions they
solve complex equations using computers
and the fastest one gets new coins
- oh no - recent Evora at the whole top
Queen a cockatoo dengue die easy oh my
god this is over they would've put all
this on a machine de-mining orthotic in
each Yvonne Shuichi go to Dairy Queen
another is a drama queen no feed on
calamity RINO dated a working atari
soniku in the pocket you know very ba
it's what you know who Tim it is no God
when you create a cryptocurrency you
have to convince this community that
your coin is worth mining so we're going
to create WH a coin are you willing to
mine it and what are the conditions hi
Ethel once to show you guys a demo daddy
Bob I know my English mmm we'll see what
we can do okay back to the city I think
we're ready to do
we found a developer Makoto Takamiya I
know nice to see you an American who
moved to Japan and created a blockchain
starter wsj coin what do you think yeah
this is very easy to do it's actually
something that I think could be
accomplished even within a single date
first you have to choose the type of
blockchain you're gonna use there are
many options nowadays and they're all
different
Bitcoin is slow but widely adopted
aetherium is faster and cheaper to
operate hyper ledger is a closed system
completely controlled by the coins
creator the WSJ coin we're gonna use
Aroha a blockchain created by makoto and
his team of 43 developers and then
choose the name and a logo that's easy
so how many of these damn coins should
we make I have no idea how do we figure
that up we decided to use the average of
the ten most popular crypto currencies
of worldwide so as you can see the
average calculated is a point four
billion coins eight point four billion
sounds good great we then chose the
level of precision of the coin what
would you recommend I think twos is
useful because the US dollar just
stupidly use like dollars and cents whew
thanks bucket oh and we're done this is
it all we have to do is push this button
and you can create wsk coin let's do it
and done your currency is created I
think we have a coin for now our eight
point four billion wsj coins are just
lines of code stored on Mikoto's private
servers let's see what we could
potentially do with them
why wouldn't we buy some drinks so we're
gonna be able to drink on division a's
dime or SS J's coin
not so fast we need him to create a
payment system for our currency so first
we need to register the bartender is a
user in the system then we consented
money we're with The Wall Street Journal
and we just launched our very own
cryptocurrency wsj coin so we'd like to
buy some beer okay can we get beer with
wsj coin that's a good question
like any crypto I basically have to come
up with a value the equivalent of one
beer and hope that my counterpart will
accept it great sending the money is a
cumbersome process Maputo spends
approximately 45 minutes coding just to
create an account for the bartender
sweaty drops the beer right now to
create the currency register an account
now we just have to transfer our asset
or does let's try this
so we should decide how many beers move
on to beers the two beers for two coins
okay so let's go and send it it's son
wsj coins first transaction Wow come
fight we convinced one shop to accept
our cryptocurrency but for wsj coin to
truly be successful we need to do what
bitcoin did convince people one by one
that our currency is credible and has
value
it's hoshi Taguchi is the head of a
major crypto exchange that's like a
stock exchange a marketplace where
people buy and sell crypto currencies it
so she says developing a payment system
is key to the success of crypto
currencies that's something all
cryptocurrencies Bitcoin included are
still lacking mostly I'm sure Diana suka
Tony La Jolla who's my estate suka
Palacio any case I see Dantas it's
Carlton a katana have also come Tatyana
connotation motif in unison yes I know
on a branded equity owner he's joining
guru Bertrand even almost oh right a
guinea some other Monica says she done
to stay its capital of Aikido a castle
suka another como same opacity of bikini
Jojo can throw 62 - ooh that's a deal
[Music]
back in Hong Kong it's time to introduce
wsj coin to the crypto community we came
to this big crypto conference with more
than 1,000 industry experts
entrepreneurs and investors I'm rich
enough never to work again in my life
we're looking for people who'd be
interested in wsj coins let's see what
people say what's your view of crypto
currencies and blockchain technology
cryptocurrencies going to change the
world
second you internet so it's going to
grow bigger and bigger
there is no borders for Bitcoin each
huge business will have their own tokens
all right you got it
people here love cryptocurrencies are
they gonna like ours at The Wall Street
Journal we're in the process of creating
W sjws a coin excuse me what do you
think yeah it's one of the biggest
initiatives by an existing company
honestly the pitch is going very well
[Music]
thank you
would you buy it
when I buy it yeah yeah nice what
wouldn't be clean dude yeah so that's in
we're trying to iron out exactly the
business model that we want to do we
want people to buy subscriptions using
our new tokens and we think that this is
a good way to attract a new audience
which so would you buy it no yeah I
guess I need to say yes implement
cameras right sorry but no many people
are trying to apply blockchain to
whatever you know comes to their mind
simply because there's a hyper rounded I
think you have to think about whether
the technology actually brings something
to the table and is useful to that kind
of industry and there are projects out
there where even I do have trouble
sometimes understanding why they now
need blockchain all of a sudden and as
an investor I think you should be on the
lookout for those that have a practical
application in other words the more
people are convinced a currency is
useful the more likely its value will
increase there's one more thing we can
do to promote our coin we're gonna get
ourselves a physical point true that's
useless but that's what a lot of people
do in the virtual currency universe
oh my
what a sweet-looking coin isn't it
beautiful
why wouldn't you buy this now
I decided to target my audience Here I
am at the WSA's annual tech conference
in the Hong Kong will wsj coin save the
newspaper industry there are about 150
people in this room right here eating
dinner I am going to pitch wsj coin in
case you can't tell I'm just a little
bit nervous a lot of important people
over there I'm hoping it goes really
well fingers crossed you all were
distributed W state coins these are
prototypes just to be perfectly clear is
there a use case for the journalism
industry in the media industry to have a
token the panelists think wsj coin could
revolutionize the way we pay for news I
don't live in the States I don't have a
subscription and I wanted to get access
to an article and often you know I get
blocked by US media and have to whip out
my credit card which is annoying for
like a small per article payment so
crypto currencies are digital currencies
where micro transactions make sense it's
a great use case for a wall even the
former CTO of Ripple one of the world's
largest cryptocurrency companies agrees
with this if you lower the costs of
moving money around you know the entire
economy changes and the entire like how
do I pay for a news article online it
changes you know I could pay suddenly
just by being on the website and my
browser streams payments on the
background
this has been great thank you both so
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
so should we officially launch wsj coin
you know actually sell the coins to
investors well it's not that simple we
have a process at The Wall Street
Journal the standards and ethics group
at the Wall Street Journal ensures our
commitment to the highest journalistic
principles there's one person he's an
institution here and he has to approve
any of our projects that raise ethical
questions my name is Neil Lipshutz
and I'm the editor for ethics and
standards at the Wall Street Journal we
had a few conversations with him so Neil
wsj coin our cryptocurrency can we
launch it this could be a way to save
the newspaper industry sorry state you
know we're not in the business of
getting into the cryptocurrency world
we're here to report it and to explain
it just like we report on banks we don't
go out and start a bank we're not gonna
create a curse a lot of crypto players
have actually criticized journalists
because they say that they are not
involved in the industry and if you
don't own any crypto you don't
necessarily have the knowledge or
expertise that people who are in the
industry do have if we had a competitive
competing entity in the very area that
we cover I think people could reasonably
lose some trust in our objectivity well
what can I say to that
I asked Makoto to shut it down right too
bad with wsj coin I could have made so
much money like all these crypto
millionaires boy is officially a Bitcoin
millionaire this is insane Oh a drive
fancy cars
they party for days on cruise ships
people call me the crypto captain they
just live the good life
Bitcoin pays but advances and I could
have been one of them I could have made
this company rich really rich
or we could have lost everything that
happens to a lot of people in the crypto
industry Bitcoin tumbling again prices
surged and plunged like crazy bear
market will continue for digital
currencies you bit is exchanges get
hacked many people lose money regulation
is still weird and they're still really
almost no protection for investors
Bitcoin is a bubble this is really a
wild world it was awesome seeing how
this crypto universe works and meeting
all these people but you know what after
all I'm not sure I want to be part of
this for the time being I'll stick to
journalism
[Music]
so let's do some one militarist let's
just about it so now it's reading it Oh
[Music]
at The Wall Street Journal now we're
going to launch our own cryptocurrency
whoa Oh teddy
oh so our own token Wow
[Music]
thank you